SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Well welcome.
I'm Scott Giambastiani.
I'm the global program
chef here.
Thank you for coming, lots
of familiar faces.
So before she was a Food
Network star and an
internationally bestselling
cookbook author, Nigella
Lawson decided she wanted
to be Italian.
At the age of 17 she spent
her gap year working as a
chambermaid and learned a wealth
of hands-on knowledge
in Italian cooking.
Today Nigella brings as much of
Italy as she can into her
own kitchen.
And now she celebrates the
pleasures of Italian food with
us and her first Italian
cookbook, "Nigellissima: Easy
Italian-Inspired Recipes."
Nigella Lawson, food
enthusiast, television
personality and journalist, is
the author of eight bestselling
cookbooks,
including "Nigella Kitchen,"
"Nigella Fresh," "Nigella
Christmas."
NIGELLA LAWSON: They all
have my name on them.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: "Nigella
Express," "Feast," "Nigella
Bites," "How to Be a Domestic
Goddess." You can see Nigella
weekly as she hosts the
innovative culinary
competition series "The Taste"
with Anthony Bourdain, which
premiered January in 2013 on
the ABC Television Network.
So with further ado,
please help me
welcome Nigella Lawson.
NIGELLA LAWSON: Thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Your book
mentions that you have instant
Italian inspiration.
I'd love if you could describe
that a little bit.
NIGELLA LAWSON: I will do.
I'm going to answer it a bit
differently which is that I
spent a year in Italy in
between high school and
university.
We have something called a gap
year, which I think everyone
should have, so you don't
think of college as a
continuation of just being
at high school.
You learn about the world and
you realize how lucky you are
to spend three or four years
studying rather than doing
what I did, which was clean
restrooms in a hotel in Italy.
However, I learned about being
Italian, and I learned to
speak Italian and
cook Italian.
I always want access to that.
Even though I'm not Italian, I
have pretended to myself for
many years that I am, even going
to the extent of giving
my children Italian names.
However, as I did say that
we have to be authentic.
And that's not suddenly
pretending to run some sort of
Disney World Italy.
It's about bringing in the
experience we have in life and
accessing them at the same time
as being true to who we
are, the traditions, cooking
and otherwise, that we've
inherited, that we've
lived through.
And for me Italian food is
actually very contemporary,
even though it's probably
one of the
most ancient of cuisines.
It's very direct, it's very
straightforward, it's very simple.
So when I want to have instant
Italian food, I'm not taking
recipes which may be--
obviously there are some
slow cook recipes--
I'm not taking some very
complicated recipe and then
trying to find some new,
contemporary twist on it,
which sometimes I'm bringing
my own twist.
I'm respecting the way that
Italians feel, that the real
truth of food is that it must
always taste of what it is.
It's not about interfering and
trying to show your own
brilliance.
And someone once said that
there's a difference between
French food and Italian food--
and if there's any French
people here I
don't mean any offense--
which is that French cooking is
about drawing attention to
the cook and Italian cooking
is about drawing
attention to the food.
And I think that's
very important.
Of course the two things
co-exist, but the real point
about trying to have what
I call instant Italian
inspiration is by thinking,
what do the
Italians do so well?
What they do is they think,
how can I respect the
ingredients in the
best way I can?
Therefore I'm interfering the
least, but having enough of
myself that I've put
my heart into this.
It's not really about knowledge,
it's about passion.
And it's about an attitude.
And I think that's very
important, and it's more
important than any amount
of rarefied knowledge.
Perhaps that sounds defensive.
I'm a home cook and
not a chef.
But the difficulty about being a
chef, often, is that you can
over think something.
Whereas what home cooks know is
that the fastest, simplest,
most straightforward way you
get food on the table
is often the best.
So that for me is very much what
Italian food is about.
And also that Italian food does
not rely on a huge amount
of ingredients.
And so when I'm writing a recipe
I feel, since I'm a
working mother who writes food
books, I know that I do not
ever want to be sent to the
shops unnecessarily.
And I never want to send other
people to the shops
unnecessarily.
And because as well not being
a chef, I'm not--
my mind is slightly blown away
by the fact that I know that
Google just here creating
45,000 meals a day.
Well as a home cook I'm not
going anywhere near that,
despite the fact that
I have teenagers.
But I will certainly
say that what
restaurant chefs often forget--
I don't mean this
disrespectfully, some of my
best friends are chefs--
but they often forget that in
a normal life, if you buy
something you're not using
a whole bottle a day.
You're not using gallons of
one particular liqueur.
So that I will always try and
make things instantly
accessible to my readers
and to myself.
Say, for example, I ask someone
to get Marsala, I will
use it in many, many recipes.
Not just because that's what
I do, but because why buy
something ever for
one ingredient?
So I'm trying as much as
possible not to be wasteful of
anyone's time, anyone's money,
or just the produce.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: That's a
great common theme that I
think a lot of cookbooks out
there make it challenging for
the home chefs.
And I appreciate the simplicity
you're putting in
and the background.
That's very, very helpful.
That kind of leads to the next
question, which is, there's a
common theme of simplicity
with ingredients and
respecting the fact that it's
the food speaking for itself.
If you're looking at the
different regions in Italy--
obviously there are dramatic
differences--
could you describe one of your
more favorite regions and why?
NIGELLA LAWSON: I will do it and
I want to link that to why
I've actually not been at all
regional in this book.
I first went to Florence, and I
have to say because of that
Tuscany has a particular
place in my heart.
The English have long
had a love affair--
and in fact, an English writer
once dubbed that part of Italy
"Chianti-shire." That's how
we end all our counties.
I actually wanted to take--
well I first wanted to do an
Italian book years and years
ago because of having
lived in Italy.
And I actually have a degree
in medieval and modern
languages from Oxford.
And Italian was one of the
languages I studied there.
I did want to do a more
academic book.
That was a long time ago when I
had the arrogance of youth.
And since then also,
the Italian
food market has exploded.
And I felt there was no need
for me, and non-Italian, to
contribute.
And there are many books
on that subject.
However, I do think that
possibly not since the Roman
Empire has Italy colonized
the world as it has now.
And Italian food is incredibly
popular I think for the
reasons I said earlier.
I am not from one of the regions
in Italy and this is
not a collection of recipes
that actually exist
everywhere.
Some of them are traditional,
some of them are my
reinterpretations.
But I was in conversation with
Mario Batali the other day.
And he was saying that he
regards in many ways the food
he does as what he calls "New
Yorkchese" And he said, would
you say that your food
is "Londonese"?
And I think that's true.
So I feel that I go to Italy a
lot, rather interestingly,
considering Italians are not
normally Anglophone.
Of the non-Anglophone countries,
for example, on
Twitter the highest number of
followers I have are from
Italy, which is extraordinary.
And I have grown to see that
what's happened in Italy is
they are fiercely regional
in their cooking.
But of course, the world
has changed.
There's the Internet, we know.
That also an enormous amount
of television.
People like Jamie Oliver
and I am also on
television in Italy.
And they're open to that.
No whereas is initially, if
you're from Tuscany you will
be very disdainful, perhaps, of
the cooking of Lazio in the
Rome region.
Italians are becoming very, very
interested in the food
that hitherto has been sort
of closed to them.
Through TV, through the
Internet, that exists.
So for example, most Italians
now, they've heard of American
muffins, they cook them.
And they use that word.
They're very interested
particularly in the Anglo
American baking tradition.
So I feel that, in a way, the
food I offer is like a new
region of Italy.
It's those of us who don't come
from Italy itself but who
are so inspired by their food.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So you
mentioned technology.
And I'm sure this question is
going to come up so I'm going
to ask it now.
Social media, how has it played
a role in your life,
especially with your
career now?
NIGELLA LAWSON: Well I've
never quite come
to terms with Facebook.
But I absolutely
adore Twitter.
And I tweet pretty much
everything I eat, and
unfortunately that's
an awful lot.
I find the interaction with
people who are interested in
food very inspiring.
And I also feel, there's
something I feel very strongly
about life, which is that there
are certain areas which
are very important
in our lives.
But somehow the amateur has
been disdained, and in the
most important areas
of it all.
We live in an age which pays too
much respect or reveres,
sometimes inappropriately,
the expert.
And the two areas I've been
thinking of are eating and
child rearing.
Now if you needed to be an
expert in either, human beings
would have fallen out of the
evolutionary loop an awfully
long time ago.
So I think what's very, very
interesting about social
media, about the whole way
people can access information
now, is that when I research
a recipe I
don't go to the experts.
If I'm interested in a
particular recipe it could be,
say pasta all'Amatriciana I
might go to just various
recipes, whether they're written
in English or Italian,
of normal people who cook.
These are the recipes that have
been passed on in their
family or how they've
adapted it.
So I think it's very important
for me, I like to see how
people cook in their homes.
I love restaurants.
The minute I know I'm going
anywhere all I do is scour the
Internet to see where
I'm going to eat.
But nevertheless, for me the
story of cooking is how actual
people cook in their lives,
not how they cook
professionally.
So as far as I'm concerned it
gives me a connection, and a
connection that I value.
And also because if you do
what I do, which is do TV
programs and write books,
that sometimes it
could be a bit one-sided.
So the same reason I like the
more old tech version of doing
a book signing, why I like
Twitter and I like any other
medium that accords me
communication with my readers.
I like that because I feel food
is about communication.
And that means it's a dialogue,
not a monologue.
And there I shut up.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Thank you.
So we're based here in Mountain
View, California.
And for the American readers,
even though we have a very
diverse group here, curious
about what recipe or recipes
do you think would stand out
to the American cooks, the
American chefs, from
your book and why?
NIGELLA LAWSON: Before I answer
that-- see, I'm a bit
of a [INAUDIBLE]--
before I answer that I want
to say that in Europe the
particularly it's
interesting--
it's not surprising
in America that--
the Renaissance, if you like, of
Italian cooking, the way it
took over from French, did not
come from Italy, although
those of us in England live very
near it, but came from
California.
You're all too young to
remember, but the big sort of
Cal-Ital movement in the '80s
is what made Italian food
suddenly come to prominence.
Now I would say that America is
a country which has so many
Italians, those of Italian
descent, that there are
certain recipes which would
stand out in particular.
And I would say my quick
Calabrian lasagna would.
That is actually very much
a traditional recipe.
And that's quite interesting in
that the normal lasagna we
know has as a white sauce,
and cheese in
it, and a meat sauce.
And there's a recipe for lasagna
in Calabria which is
entirely different.
I've never found it anywhere
outside there.
And that is you just make
a very quick meat sauce.
In other words, you just toss
some meat in a pan with some
onion, and a bit of red
wine, and lots of--
we call it passata,
tomato passata.
I don't know what
you would call.
It's pureed.
It's like--
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NIGELLA LAWSON: Paste.
No it's not paste.
It's not paste.
Whatever it'll be translated
into American in my book.
Imagine if you had some canned
tomatoes and you put them
through a food mill.
[INAUDIBLE] little better?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
NIGELLA LAWSON: Maybe it's
called puree, but I will get
to the bottom of this.
But anyways you make your sauce
like that, and that is
your very runny sauce.
And then you layer up lasagna
sheets with hard boiled eggs
chopped, mozzarella chopped, and
some cooked Italian ham,
thinly sliced.
And they layer that up, and then
you pour all the sauce
over it, and you just bake it.
Now that, I think will speak.
It's simple, it's got a
directness that will make
sense to Americans.
I think most will, zucchini
pasta, I think, especially
around here where you
probably grow your
zucchini just outside.
And I wanted to put that recipe
in because I feel--
and here I must take some
blame for this--
that anyone who prints recipes
either in magazines, or books,
or does them on TV--
although TV is more forgiving
but certainly in print--
tends to highlight
the photogenic.
And as we all know, often
the best tasting
food isn't so pretty.
And the zucchini pasta, you do
cook the zucchini a long time.
It goes a kind of [INAUDIBLE]
shade.
And it tastes so fantastic.
And I also wanted to highlight
that sort of food that's very,
really there are about
three ingredients.
It's very quick and simple.
It's not created for
a photo opp.
And I haven't really answered
your question.
But you're a probably better
place to answer.
Because I offer what I've done
and I offer it in the food
that all food should
be offered, to
share and with love.
But I cannot then look at it
as if I were an American.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Sure,
no I think you
answered it quite well.
So I want to shift to one
question about "The Taste"
because it's the new show
that you're on.
And I'm sure people have
a lot of questions.
And in the meantime if people
in the audience have
questions, it would be
a good time to start
thinking about that.
And then as you line up
behind the podium
we'll address those.
So the new show "The Taste,"
it's a huge hit.
Wanted to know what specifically
you've learned
while being on the show.
NIGELLA LAWSON: What
did I learn.
Well funnily enough, although
when I started one of the
reasons I wanted to do it is
that I feel that, as I said,
food has been slightly taken
over by the professional.
And I often think that, as great
as chefs can be, their
technique, and their expertise,
and their dexterity
while inspiring can sometimes
be intimidating.
And so I wanted to go on to
champion the home cook and to
say look, the food that we all
like eating, even the chefs
like eating, is cooked
at home.
I still feel that, but what I
learned an awful lot is that
actually those techniques
and their expertise.
And I say that really actually
a lot from watching Chef Ludo
Lefebvre cook.
Because we didn't actually see
the contestants cook, because
that was the whole point,
it was tasting blind.
And it impressed me
an awful lot.
And it showed me what artistry
can elevate food.
Not to a higher sphere, but to
a very interesting sphere.
What it also taught me is that
the one food stuff that is
absolutely impossible to taste
and to find blind is protein.
I mean, Ludo, everyone-- we had
such great chefs like Jose
Andres, everyone came on.
No one could ever tells was
it pork, was it chicken?
Ludo and I had a long argument
about whether someone's beef
was seasoned properly.
It was lamb.
And it's very interesting
because vegetables you can
tell, spice you can
tell, and herbs.
Protein you can't.
So in a way-- and I'm
a carnivore--
I would say if I were a
vegetarian, I be jumping up
and down with glee.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Was it
challenging being the only
woman on the show as far
as the judges go?
NIGELLA LAWSON: It was
challenging being the only
woman in the sense that there
were very shouty boys.
Luckily I have an older brother
and so I'm used to
keeping them in order.
But the difficulty
is I'm not--
they're professionals.
And I've always though one of
the differences between a
professional chef and a home
cook it's that professional
chefs are very conflict
driven.
And I think those of us who
cook at home tend to be--
tend, this is all
generalizations.
It can be dangerous--
tend to be conflict averse.
And although we often
fail, we try and use
food to create harmony.
So I found it quite difficult to
be in an environment where
there was a lot of alpha
male chest beating.
And how much they were going
to crush everyone else and
they were going to win.
Because the difficulty with
intimidation tactics is they
can intimidate.
And I was often quite
intimidated.
And actually although Ludo looks
like he can be really
horrible on camera, off camera
he's very nice and he always
said to me afterwards, I
didn't mean to do that.
You know more about food than
I do. (FRENCH ACCENT) I just
know fancy French foufou.
You know more about food.
But actually I did find
it intimidating.
And that was the plan.
So that was my fault.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Well said.
NIGELLA LAWSON: I also felt--
this has been reported--
slightly intimidated by the
glamorization ideal of TV.
And when we did the poster I did
say, you cannot airbrush
my tummy out.
Because I know that everyone
else on TV is thin, and I felt
very wary of that.
I didn't think it was honest
to present an airbrushed
[INAUDIBLE]
or this no tummy person.
Because I eat, and you can't eat
and have a concave tummy.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
There you go.
You mentioned in the beginning
of the book, you're trying to
make it easier for
the home chefs.
And a question around
basic ingredients.
If you had to pick five basic
ingredients to introduce chefs
to this cookbook, what
would they be?
NIGELLA LAWSON: OK, I'm going
to start with alcohol.
And that is simply this, is
that I'm rare among the
English, which is I don't open
and drink a bottle of wine
every night.
And I find that when I follow
a recipe and it wants some
wine, I don't really want to
open a bottle just for that.
So I'm a great champion
of vermouth.
We call it "vermuth" but
I'm going native now.
And it is cheaper than wine.
I mean good vermouth is cheaper
than good wine.
And you keep it in
your cupboard.
I have pink, the rose, it's
rosato, I have red, and
unfortunately I think in the
States mostly you could only
get the sweet red.
And white, dry white.
So that if I need wine in a
recipe, that I just unscrew
the top, I use the splash that
I need, I put it back, and it
lasts like sherry lasts.
So I feel that saves you
money and is useful.
And particularly, when you're in
a hurry and you're cooking
fast, red wine generally takes
a long time to cook out.
Whereas vermouth has already
been mellowed, so you just put
it in and you're ready to go.
I feel that unwaxed organic
lemons a very important.
Because when I use an
ingredient I like
to use all of it.
And lemon juice is an essential
flavoring tool for
me, whether it's in something
you want sharpness or to bring
out sweetness.
But I like to use the
zest and I like to
grate that in as well.
But obviously if it's been waxed
as most have, you're
just putting wax in your food.
So that is essential.
I'm very unfashionable in that
I like salt, but I really do
feel it's important
to get good salt.
Most times I travel
with my own salt.
I think you call it
kosher salt here.
I use malden or I use
French fleur de sel.
Because otherwise I feel you go
out and you've got lovely
food in front of you, and then
someone puts some shaker with
bathroom scourer on the table.
So good salt is very
important.
I'm very fond of something that
purists hate, which is
garlic infused oil.
Because on days when you crawl
home and you're so tired that
the idea of peeling garlic and
crushing it make you feel like
weeping, just having that mild
garlic is very good.
Also, the Italians don't
over garlic.
What Italians do-- and this is
also an important ingredient--
is use olive oil.
And then you put a peeled clove
of garlic, and you cook
it until it's golden, and
then you get rid of it.
They do not put huge
amounts of garlic.
And the last thing I would say
is everyone has been so
brainwashed into using
extra virgin olive
oil and all the time.
Italians never ever use extra
virgin olive oil to cook.
It's very expensive, when it's
heated you lose the taste.
Always buy regular olive
oil to cook with.
Extra virgin olive oil goes
on after you've cooked.
A teeny drop and you have that
fantastic fragrance, but it is
both wasteful and unnecessary to
use it when you're cooking.
And not least as well is that
the smoking point I think of
extra virgin olive oil
is lower than of
regular olive oil.
So if you're going to cook
anything at high heat it'll
burn faster.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: So
now you have it.
Five easy ingredients
to get started.
NIGELLA LAWSON: I may
not have done five.
I am innumerate.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: I
think you got it.
Think you got it.
So in the beginning of your
travels through Italy, you
make some references about
eating on a budget.
Any tips?
NIGELLA LAWSON: Yes certainly.
I have a recipe here which I
lived on when I was young and
I cook an awful lot now.
And it's called Eggs
in Purgatory.
And I have referred to it--
some people think there may be
some reference to Dante.
I have gone into it to some
length in [INAUDIBLE]
which is simply, you
get a skillet.
You put a bit of olive
oil what's sort.
A bit of garlic, some oregano,
and some Chile flakes.
And then you open a can
of diced tomatoes
which you put in.
You crack open as many
eggs as you need.
You then grate over some
Parmesan and you cook it for a
few minutes.
It's the most fantastic--
it's great if you're hungover.
I know none of you here
ever would be.
It's fantastic when you want
something quick, and it
doesn't cost very much.
But it's good food,
it's real food.
And just a hunk of lovely bread,
such as you get a lot
around here, and you're away.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Great.
If audience has questions,
please start lining up.
I'm going to continue.
So what would you
say, if any--
other than what you've
discussed--
are some key takeaways
from the book.
And one of the key takeaways
that I had right off the bat
is you're telling people to read
through the recipe first,
which I thought was great.
And you're emphasizing
simplicity.
Any other key takeaways from
your point of view that you'd
like to talk to the
audience about?
NIGELLA LAWSON: I started off
as a journalist, not a food
journalist at that.
And for me a recipe is a bit
like a piece of journalism in
that it has to adhere to the
questions of who, what, why,
when and why now.
And I think that's what
we should when
we're cooking as well.
And I have tried to put each
recipe in context.
And I think that's what
we all need to do.
When you take a recipe
into your life it
has to become yours.
So although there are many
recipes in here, I would say
just choose some you like, cook
those few over and over
again, and then change them
and make them yours.
Because even though I write
cookbooks, it's very important
not to be enslaved by the
tyranny of the recipe.
I know that everything works.
I test everything
in my own home.
I feed my children
and my friends.
And the baking recipes I do a
quadruple testing by sending
out to people who use
different ovens.
I know everything works, so
you can rely on that.
Use them and then change it.
Because cooking has to be
authentic to who we all are
personally.
So I want to share what I've
got and then you add what
you've got.
And if any of you want to let
me know how you've changed
things, I sometimes change
things in further additions.
If readers say to me, you
know what I changed it
a bit, I did that.
I will change a recipe in later
editions, because as I
say, it's about communication.
And you must always remember
to put yourself in your
cooking, because that's like.
And if you don't do that you're
not really part of the
recipe an of the dish
yourselves.
But you can follow the
recipe as well.
I'm happy if you want to cook
from it directly, and I know
it will work.
But not to feel that you
can't put your stamp.
And that's what I want
people to take away.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
We have a very
innovative bunch of Googlers.
I think you're going to get
a lot of emails coming in.
That's great.
We have a first question
from the audience.
AUDIENCE: My wife and I first
saw you on TV in Australia
where we're from eleven
years ago.
NIGELLA LAWSON: You don't say.
AUDIENCE: My wife's
up the front here.
It was 11 years ago
on our honeymoon.
So ever since then you've been
the other woman in our
relationship.
And so there's lots of things
I'd like to ask you but I'll
give you two.
We've got four young children,
could you tell us of your
recipes which you think
the kids would love to
eat and help make?
We love seeing that on your TV
shows with your kids helping
to make things.
NIGELLA LAWSON: Yes.
AUDIENCE: And the other
thing I'd love to
hear about your writing.
To become a writer, were you
just passionate about it?
Did you study?
So I'll leave you with those.
NIGELLA LAWSON: OK I will
answer in the order.
People often complain that
children don't eat vegetables.
I think actually it really
depends on how you cook them
and how you talk about it.
I've got a recipe in here
which is for tortellini
minestrone, which my children
have always loved.
And a big bowl of vegetable
soup is
nourishing in every sense.
It's nourishing the
body and the soul.
And since my children were
little I would give then
scissors for them to chop
up green beans.
I feel that--
I think your children are
probably too young to be given
knives but they can stir--
and I think that really it's
being part, even if they're
just watching in with you in the
kitchen and being part of
seeing how food is made
is very important.
And if they contribute,
they will eat.
Even if Brussels sprouts, which
children often don't
like, you ask them to help cook
them, they will eat them
because children want to--
we all, we need to
feel involved.
And so that's what I
would say in there.
And also my children
particularly like, I call it a
pasta risotto.
When I was in Italy last I found
this new way where they
have a cooking pasta, which
is totally anarchic.
Which is you put pasta and water
in together and you cook
until the pasta has absorbed
the water.
And it's very, very creamy.
And I use that orzo pasta, which
looks like rice although
orzo in fact means barley.
And I cook that with pancetta or
bacon and peas, frozen peas
I'm afraid to say.
I shouldn't say I'm afraid to
say because, of course, unless
you're picking the peas and
shucking them straight away,
you're just getting the starch,
you're not getting
everything.
And they like that a lot.
And it's very easy to make
because you're not stirring
like risotto.
You can't have four young
children and be stirring a
risotto, that I know.
As for writing, I'll tell you
how I learned to write.
And that is very strangely that
when I was at college--
I don't know if it's
still done but--
if you went to either Oxford or
Cambridge, you were taught
in the tutorial system, which
was just one-to-one with your
tutor or sometimes two of you.
And you didn't hand your essay
in, you had to read it out.
I mean obviously this wouldn't
work if you were doing math.
But I was doing, as I say,
medieval and modern languages.
And when I did my first essay,
like many children, young
people who were academically
precocious, it was
embarrassingly pretentious.
And I was too embarrassed
to read it out loud.
So I had to edit as I read it
out so that I could say it
without brushing.
And then I learned to write.
Some people might say I still do
have a slight illiteration
and adjectival overload
problem.
But I'm working on it.
I learned how to be a journalist
that way and I
learned how to write.
Because in order to hold
someone's attention and for it
to be realistic that one should
say something, you have
to learn to write in a way
that will do that.
So I would say that was the best
training for writing I
could possibly have had.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Great.
So lots of great savory dishes
and in the book and also a lot
of yummy desserts.
What would be one of your
favorite desserts and why?
NIGELLA LAWSON: There's two
particular desserts, can I do
two, please?
Can I be greedy?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: You
could to three.
NIGELLA LAWSON: One
is my chocolate
olive oil cake, which--
this is really a bit about--
it's not Italian because it's
got olive oil I kind of gave
myself a bit of license.
I created it because a very good
friend of mine has celiac
disease and he complained to
me that he never got to eat
chocolate cake anymore.
So I wanted to make a cake he
could-- so it's really just--
its got ground almonds
instead of flour and
it's got olive oil.
So it's gluten free and
dairy free, and
is fudgy and heavenly.
And very easy to make because
you're really just stirring,
stirring some hot water into
some cocoa, and then you're
stirring some olive oil,
and sugar, and
eggs, and ground almonds.
So it's very, very easy.
You make it ahead,
so I love that.
And I also have what I call a
one-step no-churn coffee ice
cream, which is made from
ingredients that would
probably give most
nutritionists a nervous breakdown.
But condensed milk, heavy
cream, instant espresso
powder, and coffee liqueur.
I have to say I'm unashamedly
kitsch.
And it tastes like
Italian gelato.
And all you is whisk it all
together, put it straight in
the freezer, and you don't have
to churn it or anything,
because it has so much
sugar and fat.
But you don't have to eat a lot
and you don't have to eat
it every day.
That's what I say, so those
are my two favorites.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Perfect.
We have another question?
AUDIENCE: We know that you
love Italian food.
What other types of
food do you like?
NIGELLA LAWSON: All types.
AUDIENCE: What would be your
favorite cuisines?
NIGELLA LAWSON: I have yet to
find a type of food I don't
like except a green pepper.
I feel they're unripe and
I don't understand it.
I feel if you're not Hungarian,
there's no excuse
for a green bell pepper.
I love Thai food.
And I think of all the Asian
cuisines it's the simplest to
cook at home.
I like Indian food but I cook
that only when I've got either
a lot of time off or a
pressing deadline.
Because you have to work
so hard on it.
I think otherwise the only
other cuisine I have an
emotional connection
to really is
Norwegian, strangely enough.
Because for some reason I spent
a lot of time in Norway
as a child and even did
once speak Norwegian.
I can't anymore.
So I love Scandinavian food.
And I also adore regional
American food.
For me it's incredibly exotic.
And I collect all those--
I go around America and I
collect all those spiral bound
recipe books that I know
churches or communities put
together of their recipes
and I love that.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Are there
any areas that you maybe
haven't been to that you'd
like to explore more?
Or you've been to and you'd
like to see move
of around the world?
NIGELLA LAWSON: I'm very, very
ill traveled and I would like
to rectify that.
It's partly because
I have children.
They're getting older,
but as they get older
they still need you.
And I very much--
I do this work and I love it.
But I do it also so that I can
work and feed my family.
I mean a bit like the
environment here is that I
want to live a life
in which I feel
completely integrated person.
That I'm not a work person and
then not a work person.
I'm just me.
And the difficulty of that is
that it means that, much as
I'd like to travel hugely, I
want to be at home as well.
So later on when I'm and old
battle axe, I'm going to--
I'm getting near there--
I am going to go around
the world.
And I certainly would love
to go to the Far East.
I would love to travel.
I think it'd be great to just
say, for a year or so I'm just
going to travel and eat my
way around the world.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Love
it, love it, love it.
So I have one final question
and it's maybe a glimpse of
the future for you.
Any future projects
you can share?
NIGELLA LAWSON: I really,
really hate plans.
I don't know if--
do you do Myers-Briggs
at Google?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Oh, yes.
NIGELLA LAWSON: Do you
approve it or not?
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI:
Yeah, it's used.
NIGELLA LAWSON: OK I'm
ESFP, we don't plan.
We do not plan.
We are spontaneous
improvisers.
And give me a form to fill
in or a plan to have an I
dwindle, diminish, and wilt.
I have a few things in
the back burner.
And I just carry on.
And I see what emerges.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: Brilliant.
Thank you very much.
NIGELLA LAWSON: Thank you.
SCOTT GIAMBASTIANI: It's been
a pleasure, thank you.